the Dow Jones Industrial Average will
open at a record high the index gained
218 points yesterday roughly 36 hours
after there was initial turmoil on
election night the Journal says the jump
in the markets reflects a bet on Trump's
plan to stimulate the economy cut taxes
and limit financial regulations to
discuss at all CBS News financial
contributor Mellody Hobson is here
melody good morning to you are anytime
so these dire predictions about the
markets thus far after those initial
first hours have not come to pass why is
that I think there are three reasons the
first which we cannot understate is he
got the whole enchilada he got both
houses of Congress and as the Wall
Street Journal said today it's not a
question of if legislation will pass
which is what we've been dealing with
for the last several years but what
legislation will pass so I think that
sense of that gridlock being over
they've got the votes the second thing I
think that is was very important brexit
was a dress rehearsal people saw
something you know pretty dramatic
happened and the world did not end and I
think the brexit story will play out
longer-term maybe not as well as we've
seen but that initial sense of there's
been this shock we were wrong and you
know the world didn't compromise exactly
yeah stress rehearsal and then last but
not least I think this rhetoric has
helped that we've gotten away from the
very decisive divisive language
Secretary Clinton had a graceful exit
there were it was a graceful acceptance
speech and the pictures yesterday I
think were very calming it does make a
difference yeah you spoken to executives
on both sides of the aisle business
executives what are they saying to you
so you know normally mm-hmm Republican
or Democrat shock yeah uniformly in
terms of the halls of corporate America
I talked to CEOs chief financial
officers General Counsel's there is some
sense of anticipation and expectation of
better Tax Policy and the idea that they
will be able to bring some of these
dollars that have been sitting all over
the world back into the country without
paying a huge tax on this jock is not
normally considered a good thing as are
they saying shock but we're gonna be
alright or shock let's see shock let's
see the taxes is positive the
protectionist calm
are very negative so one chief financial
officer that I spoke to yesterday of a
global consumer products company said
our biggest customer in Latin America is
Mexico the rhetoric around Mexico scares
us because if our goods cost more there
or if they end up having a weak economy
we are going to feel it and so there was
a lot of concern about that and you're
obviously also hearing that in the tech
area because of the need for engineers
from around the world to help fuel the
immigrant the innovation that they have
okay who are the losers in a in a trump
administration in terms of businesses so
what we've seen so far is around the
Affordable Care Act and specifically
hospitals so they're saying if they're
less insured people we're gonna have to
eat those costs and so you've seen HCA
be one of the worst trade it stocks the
last couple days in other hospital
companies that's a big area some of the
that really interesting Melanie can I
just say you look good from top to
bottom I hope we can get a shot of your
shoes before we go today